[Music]
all right this is nice to see some
justice don't get me started
uh i know you're a fan of justice
the fbi
recently arrested a tick tock star
and the story
i rest all of it
man nick is spurned dude
i don't play man with the justice system
i don't play
get them all huh especially if it's
federal lock them all hello officers i'm
housing a tick tock star you got to come
get them lock them all up end of story
fbi yeah the fb the fbi arrested tick
tock star because they were able to
connect them to a string of robberies
based on the shoes he was wearing in the
videos yeah that's what he gets that guy
sucks that's what he gets
fbi it's a [ __ ] feral crime he has
some rare shoes or something yeah like
how specific are your shoes it's this
dude right here
[Laughter]
you know what this is really about
tick-tock don't pay man
doesn't pay dude
you get millions of [ __ ] views on
tick-tock and it doesn't give you [ __ ]
give you anything right yeah i mean he
had a he had about 150k followers on
tick-tock that's pretty good but why is
he using the same shoes too i feel like
the metrics are like way different yeah
oh yeah that's you could get that in a
day right back in the day when youtube
was like you if you didn't have a
hundred thousand followers you weren't
like nobody i feel like with tick tock
it's like you need to have like a
million followers to be like okay you're
an influencer like you're you're kind of
a little bit you exist you think about
how many views you got to get to even
get that because tick tock's such a
crazy medium you have like 10 [ __ ]
million views on the video and there's
so many people with just 10 million
followers that's why i say lock them up
dude i'm pretty boober man not that many
people should have that many followers i
think it's a lot of responsibility
higher responsibility man
do you guys actually watch it because i
i think i stay boomer like i'm on reels
i'm on instagram isn't that more like
twitter
i stay
i've been on uh crypto tick tock but
it's pretty haunting really yeah it's
because they say bad stuff or see a lot
of we have [ __ ] coins just chilling [ __ ]
coin stuff yeah why you should get big
connect yeah exactly exactly hey check
out ring financial it's going up and i'm
like oh bloody oh no there's not even
120 volume it's over
oh buddy
i love when steve does this because
that's why i know he's really troubled
well yeah this dude uh it happened in
detroit and uh all four crimes were
described in similar fashion that's
pretty good
[Laughter]
i guess he just really likes those
specific shoes and no one else has those
shoes huh it's not like a converse or
something like was it just the shoes
yeah or is it or is he robbing this
place like hey check out ring financial
it's going up i don't think this is the
thing i don't think they could have
arrested him unless he didn't
we got to just get steve doing that a
lot basically he's confessed
thank you guys thank god for dumb
criminals dude
like not to even like um yeah i've heard
some of my cop buddies saying like
there's a guy who wears the same exact
beanie when he does the robbery like
they're just like they're just dumb
or or something that's like uh you want
a cigarette there's a hoodie with this
reflective strip on it you know just
very like identifying like traits
but like they don't go to like walmart's
by the most blankest things you can find
you know yeah it's crazy that's like why
uh tattoos are really easy identifier to
find criminals it's like oh you got a
[ __ ] gigantic kitty right here that's
not me
it could be anybody man
yeah but this dude basically uh
had to say he probably could have gone
he just like had a good story but yeah
they they decided to question him
because of that and then if you fail the
questioning part and you're just like oh
yeah it was me get shaken down then yeah
they're like okay we got him so he just
admitted to it yeah it goes bad you got
it but then that's how they knew who to
check out i mean who knows how many
people they you know asked about this
that were like so the cops were on tick
tock and they go hey wait a minute
those shoes fit the description it
doesn't say how they even like i think
they oh it says they got it here we go
they got an anonymous tip to check this
guy out it's a rat it's a rat oh
[ __ ]
all disappointed
we hate a rat we just hate jk we hate
iraq you got criminals right you got
criminals are here
they're they're pretty bad but then rats
are at them i know
and even if they like donate to charity
work at shelter
what if it was the 7-eleven owner that
got robbed and he was doing his own side
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter we hate rats here it's
a rat dude it's not a rat but it's a a a
detective without jurisdiction on the
case
biggest cross fingers crossed what is
that a renegade like it's just
no jurisdiction yeah so vigilante and
rap venn diagram exists we're not big on
vigilantes in here dude oh okay got it
so no civilian can you think civilians
that are tipping off cops about
criminals are rats too 100 i mean
there's a name for it it's called karen
it's called it's called call mind your
own business unless it's your own [ __ ]
if it's your own [ __ ] then you're just
calling the cops on your own [ __ ] but if
you're like if that doesn't affect you
in any way and like hey there's this guy
i've been noticing like that guy's a rat
you know what i i i had a co-worker
um who was uh he he he's in and out of
jail all the time right and he was
telling me like when he needs a little
more money he puts a little uh weed he
gets an ounce of weed some some pills he
puts it in his butthole
he goes outside he shoots in the air and
then he calls the cops on himself
and then
he sends himself to jail because he
knows oh that's probably gonna you know
get me a couple of months i could sell
these drugs make some money come back
you know and whatever and i'm like so
you ratted on yourself so he can go into
jail and sell to sell the drugs yeah but
but the but the point is he ratted on
himself he violated the number one crime
that you do not do you don't [ __ ] rat
doesn't he know that you can smuggle
drugs into jail you gotta sell the drugs
outside the jail then you you buy a
plane
and then you can fly into the jail
right then you buy a jail yeah then you
buy in jail
well he also wanted to go see his
boyfriend too but that's just another
story i think the the main thing was he
wanted to go in sell the drugs
make more money
get free food get free lodging that
sounds more like it yeah yeah and then
you know he has a little bit saved in
his account he gets released and he
starts fresh
buys a plane
hides a flame that's what you do sticks
it up his butt flies
that's crazy how he's that person sees
jail like it's just going
like to vacation or going to another
country yeah it's gonna work it's gonna
work he's like i gotta take the uh the
bus to work for three months
you told me like guys do it all the time
when they just want a place to stay for
like six months or whatever they know
what kind of crimes or what kind of
things they gotta do for how long
they're gonna get you know set for
so they're like oh well i'm not gonna
kill anybody it's gonna take me a long
time in there or maybe they really wanna
retire and stay in there for quite some
time yeah yeah it's pretty common i
think yeah but you could sell drugs for
more than street price inside so that's
why
you can sell kind of random objects too
like just stuff they don't have rabbits
buttons
let me pull this
so people need luck in there man they're
they're
not
dark ones it's not there's not like a
middle holding cell before you get like
let in that like you just sit there
until you [ __ ] there's like a toilet oh
yeah i mean they make you squad do all
that but it's called the prison pocket
for a reason you know what i'm i
was when i was in like second grade we
had a guy speak to the class to talk
about prisons
you know like that always happens and i
just remember he he just was so cool and
inspiring he's like my friend's dad from
the classes like this nicaraguan guy and
he's like he goes you don't want to go
to jail you know what they're going to
do they're going to make you bend over
and crack a smile
and we were just like what is he talking
about
like i'm just second grade i didn't
understand that that meant you got it we
should second grade
i didn't understand that that meant you
had to spread your ass cheeks apart like
how could you infer that yeah it also
just sounds like that it also meant you
had to spread them and enjoy it
bend over and crack a smile doesn't
sound like a lot of things was he there
to scare you guys straight and [ __ ] yeah
that's it yeah second grade huh even
though you were second graders at a
seventh day adventist school how much
straighter could you possibly be
they never do a good job because like i
remember in fifth or sixth we would have
that we had like ex-cons or whatever
come in and then when they talk about
jaw uh when they caught because they're
all part of like the sane or dare
program yeah so they come they're
reformed right so they come in and when
they talk about it
the mansfield's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] and
then the next week you have like a a cop
come in that's all square and [ __ ]
you're like oh square oh dude i'd rather
be that guy that went to jail and this
guy's [ __ ] obeying all the rules
you're like yeah i don't know if a lot
of people say that but i can understand
how you said that yeah a lot of people
dare did not work on bart quan yeah a
lot of people have been saying
i think those programs definitely uh
in like in the fairness they were
seeking to have they messed up a lot
because it's like the people that come
and talk to you about abstinence i don't
know you guys probably didn't have that
at your schools because we did okay yeah
they're always the ones that
probably aren't getting a lot of options
thrown at them exactly so you're just
like well of course you're [ __ ]
abstinent like that's you're on easy
mode yeah and everyone can see it even
as a second grader you're like no one
wants to date you dude
nobody wants to have sex with you dude
it's like dragons figures show me a
[ __ ] hot ass dude
and and let him tell me that he ain't
doing that don't bring an incel into the
room come in shirtless just
have josh do mel tell me not to [ __ ]
and i want to see how he does it like
dude have [ __ ] fabio right into him
right into a room with a horse what's
the last movie he's been your [ __ ]
love joshua they do though who loves
josh dumas all the [ __ ] bro every
chick that i knew in high school i see
him at all the ufc fights too that's
right he and he buys his partner he buys
three chairs because he pops out because
he's not in that many movies
no so he'll always buy three chairs and
he's always in the middle i'm like i
think he's always buying buying out
because it's like packed section the
fact that you know his seating chart and
his seating arrangement because i see i
saw it so many times he's even told me
about it he's a fan i'm like you're
joshua
we got to get him on man i would love to
get dressed for mulan well his last
movie i think the major one he was in
his transformers
he should do abs in his psa [ __ ]
riding on a horse on a [ __ ] sunset on
the beach and [ __ ] he goes you know what
i don't [ __ ]
with he just starts here yo that's like
the old spice guy you know why i don't
[ __ ] i'm just doing mocking of any
chicken i want and i don't [ __ ]
then kids are like okay i'm listening
yeah it's like yeah it's like no fap
right you got all these guys that are
like yeah nofap you know and then it's
like no [ __ ] i think that counts for a
lot because i went back and spoke at my
high school
uh like fresh off of l mfao touring by
abstinence no about how i i had never
had a ship of alcohol
even though i'm on tour with like
that's dope yeah and that that that was
my like um i was like when i [ __ ]
grow up and like i want to do that to be
like hey guys don't do this even and i'm
going to show them that every [ __ ]
day of my life that's all over the place
and you like did the coolest [ __ ] ever
and you don't have to do this to be the
coolest [ __ ] ever versus you're a
[ __ ] loser and then and then oh i
drink water every day i'm not gonna
drink water i'm gonna turn into a
[ __ ] loser like here yeah cause then
the kids are like well then how do you
like don't they make fun of you it's
like no because
all you gotta do is still be a cool
person and they'll be like oh that's all
so cool that's true just don't be like a
dick and be like that's bad for you
don't drink
but i was [ __ ] i'll tell you that
that was my drug
[Music]
[Music]
you